una justicia igualitaria serví como
vicefiscal en la administración de biden
y obama y estuve para la transición
después de diez días fui despedida por
no defender la prohibición de viajes
desde países musulmanes ese fue el
principio de ataques hacia nuestras
instituciones democráticas y a los
servidores públicos dedicados como yo
estos oficiales no hicieron un juramento
hacia una persona o un partido en estos
servidores públicos prometieron respetar
nuestras leyes y nuestra constitución y
trabajar en nombre del pueblo
estadounidense pero desde el principio
que llegó el presidente yo era utilizado
su posición para beneficiarse a sí mismo
en lugar de nuestro país
él ha pisoteado el estado derecho ha
tratado de crear un arma desde el
departamento de justicia para proteger
sus amigos y atacar a sus enemigos
en lugar de enfrentarse a vladimir putin
siguen a un dictador que aún no quiere
interferir en nuestras elecciones él
está incluso tratando de sabotear
nuestro servicio postal para evitar que
la gente pueda votar
sus ataques constantes al fpv y a la
prensa libre a los instructores
generales a los jueces todo esto tiene
un solo propósito es evitar que se
revise su abuso de poder
y él simplemente trata a nuestro país
como si fuera su negocio familiar esta
vez llevar a nuestro a la bancarrota
moral a este país pero nuestro país no
le pertenece a ella nos pertenece a
todos nosotros
joe biden entiende esto y el han pasado
toda su vida poniendo a nuestro país
primero él nunca se ha echado para atrás
ante un reto o un bullying él ha visto
lo mejor de nosotros y vive según los
principios que nos definen como
estadounidenses el servicio la
integridad
el coraje la compasión incontables
historias de joe biden yendo a buscar a
alguien en su momento de necesidad es
bueno este es el momento de necesidad
del país necesitamos un presidente que
respete las leyes y el privilegios del
servicio público
que refleje nuestros valores que le
importen nuestra gente necesitamos un
presidente que vaya a restaurar el alma
de eeuu necesitamos a joe biden